the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
today we're going to continue with
integration and we get to do the
probably the most important thing of
this entire course which is
appropriately named it's called the
fundamental theorem of calculus and
we'll be abbreviating at FTC and
occasionally put in a 1 here because
there will be two versions of it but
this is the one that you'll be using the
most in this class the fundamental
theorem of calculus says the following
it says that if F prime is equal to F so
f prime of X is equal to little f of X
as a capital F and a little F then the
integral from A to B of f of X is equal
to F of B minus F of a that's it that's
that's the whole theorem and you may
recognize it before we had the notation
that F was the antiderivative that is
capital F was the integral of f of X we
wrote it this way this is this
indefinite integral and now we're
putting in definite values and we have a
connection between the two uses of the
integral sign but with the definite
values we get real numbers out instead
of a function or a function up to a
constant so this is it this is the
formula and it's usually also written
with another notation so I I want to
introduce that notation to you as well
so there's a new notation here which
you'll find very convenient because we
don't always have to give a name a
letter F to the functions involved so
it's an abbreviation for right now there
will be a lot of EPs but anyway so
here's the abbreviation whenever I have
a difference between a function at two
values I also can write this as f of X
with an A down here and Abby up there so
that's the notation that we use and you
can also for emphasis and this sometimes
turns out to be important when there's
more than one variable floating around
in the problem to specify that the
variable is X so this is the same thing
as x equals a and x equals B it's
indicates where you want to plug in what
you want to plug in and now you take the
top value minus the bottom value so f of
B minus F of a so this is just a
notation and in that notation of course
the the theorem can be written as with
this set of symbols here equally well
okay so let's just give a couple of
examples
the first example is the one that we did
last time very laborious ly if you take
the function capital f of X which
happens to be X cubed over three then if
you differentiate it you get well the
factor of three cancels so you get x
squared that's the derivative and so by
the fundamental theorem so this implies
by the fundamental theorem that the
integral from say A to B of X cubed over
I'm sorry
x squared DX
that's the derivative here this is the
function we're going to use as F of s
here is equal to this function here F of
B minus F of a that's here this function
here so that's right F of B minus F of a
and that's equal to b cubed over three
minus a cubed over three now in this new
notation we we usually don't have all
these letters all we write is the
following we write the integral from A
to B and I'm going to do the case 0 to B
because that was the one that we
actually did last time
so I'm going to set a equals zero here
and then the problem we were faced last
time was this and as I said we did it
very laborious ly but now you can see
that we can do it in a ten seconds let's
say well the antiderivative of this is X
cubed over three I'm going to evaluate
it at 0 and at B and subtract so that's
going to be B cubed over 3 minus zero
cubed over 3 which of course is B cubed
over 3 and that's that's the end that's
the answer so this is a lot faster than
yesterday I hope you'll agree and we can
we can dispense with those elaborate
computations although there's a
conceptual reason a very important one
for understanding the procedure that we
went through because eventually you're
going to be using integrals and these
quick ways of doing things to solve
problems like finding the volumes of
pyramids in other words we're going to
reverse the process and so we need to
understand the connection between the
two all right I'm going to give a couple
more examples and then we'll go on so
the second example would be one that
would be quite difficult to do by this
Riemann sum technique that we described
yesterday although it is possible it
uses much higher mathematics to do it
and that is the area
under under one hump of the sine curve
sine X let me just draw a picture of
that the curve goes like this and we're
talking about this area here it starts
out at zero it goes to pi
that's one hump and so the answer is
it's the integral from zero to PI of
sine X DX and so I need to take the
antiderivative of that and that's minus
cosine X that's the thing whose
derivative is sine X evaluating it at
zero and PI now let's do this one
carefully because this is where I see a
lot of arithmetic mistakes even though
this is the easy part of the problem
it's hard to pay attention and plug in
the right numbers and so let's just pay
very close attention I'm plugging in PI
that's minus cosine PI that's the first
term and then I'm subtracting the value
at the bottom which is minus cosine of
zero all right there are already five
opportunities for you to make a
transcription error or an arithmetic
mistake in what I just did and I've seen
all five of them alright so the next one
is that this is minus minus one minus
negative one if you like and then this
is minus and here's another negative one
all right so altogether we have two so
that's it that's that's the area this
area which is hard to guess this is area
two
all right the third example is maybe
superfluous but I'm going to say it
anyway we can take the integral say from
0 to 1 of X to the 100th power any any
power now is within our power so let's
do it here so here we have the
antiderivative is X to the 101 divided
by 101 evaluated at 0 and 1 and that is
just 1 over 101 ok that's that all right
so that's that's the fundamental theorem
now this as I say well what harness is a
lot of what we've already learned all
about all about anti derivatives now I
want to give you an intuitive
interpretation so let's try that we'll
talk about a proof of the fundamental
theorem a little bit later it's not
actually that hard but we'll we'll give
an intuitive reason interpretation if
you'd like of the of the fundamental
family
so this is going to be one which is not
related to area but rather to time and
distance so we'll consider X of T is the
is your position at time T and then X
prime of T which is the rate of change
of X with respect to T is going to be
what we know as your speed alright and
then what the theorem is telling us is
the following it's telling us the
integral from A to B of V of T DT so
reading the relationship is equal to X
of B minus X of a and so this is some
kind of cumulative sum of your
velocities so let's interpret the right
hand side first this is the distance
traveled and it's it's also what you
would read on your odometer right from
the beginning to the end of the trip
that's what you would read on your
odometer whereas this is what you would
read on your speedometer okay so so
we're this is the interpretation now I
want to just go one step further into
this interpretation to make the
connection with the Riemann sums that we
had yesterday because those are very
complicated to understand and I want you
to understand them viscerally on several
different levels because that's how
you'll understand integration better the
first thing that I want to imagine so
we're going to do a thought experiment
now which is that you are extremely
obsessive and you're driving your
are from from time a to time be place Q
to time to place our whatever and you
check your speedometer every second okay
so you've read your speedometer in the
eye second and you've read that you're
going at this speed now how far do you
go in that second well the answer is you
go this speed times the time interval
which in this case we're imagining is
one second all right so this is how far
you went so this is the time interval
and this is the distance traveled in
that in a second number I in the if--
second the distance traveled on the ice
X and that's the total distance you
travel now what happens if you go the
whole distance well you travel all the
the sum of all these distances so it's
some some massive somewhere and it's
some ridiculous number of seconds 3600
seconds or something like that whatever
it is and that's going to turn out to be
very similar to what you would read on
your odometer right because during that
second you didn't change velocity very
much so the approximation that the speed
at one time that you spotted it is very
similar to the speed during the whole
second it doesn't change that much so
this is a pretty good approximation to
how far you traveled and so the sum is a
very realistic approximation to the
entire integral which is denoted this
way which by the fundamental theorem is
exactly how far you traveled so this is
X of B minus X of a exactly the other
one is approximate
okay again this is this is called a
Riemann sum all right so that's the
intro to the fundamental theorem and now
what I need to do is extend it just a
bit and the way I'm going to extend it
is the following I'm going to do it on
this example first and then and then
we'll we'll do it more formally so
here's this example where we went
someplace but now I just want to draw
you an additional picture here imagine I
start here and I go over to there and
then I come back okay and maybe even I
do a roundtrip I come back to the same
place well if I come back to the same
place then the position is unchanged
from the beginning to the end in other
words the difference is zero and the
velocity technically rather than the
speed it's the speed to the right and a
speed to the left maybe are the same but
one of them is going in the positive
direction one of them is going in the
negative direction and they cancel each
other so so if you have this kind of
situation we want that to be reflected
we like that interpretation and we want
to preserve it even when in in the case
when the the note that the function V is
negative and so I'm going to now extend
our notion of integration
so we'll extend integration to the case
F negative or positive in other words it
can be any sign actually there's no
change the formulas are all the same we
just if this V is going to be positive
we write in a positive number if it's
going to be negative we write in a
negative number and we just leave it
alone
and the real sohere's let me let me
carry out an example and show you how it
works I'll carry out the example on the
this blackboard up here of the sine
function but we're going to try two
humps we're going to try the the first
hump and the one that goes underneath
there so our second examine our example
here is going to be the integral from 0
to 2pi of sine X DX and now because the
fundamental theorem is so important and
so useful and so convenient we just
assumed that it'd be true in this case
as well so we insist that this is going
to be minus cosine X evaluated at 0 and
2 pi with the difference now when we
carry out that difference what we get
here is minus cosine 2 pi minus minus
cosine 0 which is negative 1 minus
negative 1 which is 0 and the
interpretation of this is is the
following here's our double hump here's
PI and here's 2 pi and all that's
happening is that the geometric
interpretation that we had before of the
area under the curve has to be taken
with a grain of salt in other words I
lied to you before when I said that the
definite integral was the area under the
curve it's not
the definite integral is the area under
the curve when it's above the curve and
it counts negatively when it's below the
curve so yesterday my my geometric
interpretation was incomplete and really
just a plain lie so the true geometric
interpretation of the definite integral
is the plus the area above the axis
above the x-axis minus the area below
all right as in the picture I'm just
just running it down in words but but
you should think of it visually also
alright so that's the that's the setup
here and now we have the complete
definition of integrals and I need to
list for you a bunch of their properties
and how we deal with integrals are there
are there any questions before we before
we go on yeah
the right so so the question was
wouldn't the absolute value the velocity
function be involved the the answer is
yes that is that's one thing you could
one question that you could ask one
question you could ask is what's the
total distance traveled and in that case
you would keep track of the absolute
value of the of the velocity as you as
you said whether it's positive or
negative then you'll get the total
length of this curve here that's however
not what the definite integral measures
it measures the net distance traveled so
so it's it's it's another thing in other
words we can do that we now have the
tools to do both we could also so V so
if you like the the total distance is
equal to the integral of this from A to
B but the net distance is the one
without the absolute value signs all
right so that that's correct
other questions
all right so now let's talk about
properties of integrals
well so the properties of integrals that
I want to mention to you are these the
first one is doesn't bear too much
comment if you take the cumulative
integral of a sum you're just going to
get the sum of the separate integrals
here and I won't say much about that
that's because sums come at because the
the integral is a sum incidentally you
know this strange symbol here there's
actually a reason for it historically if
you go back to old books you'll see that
it actually looks a little bit more like
an S this capital Sigma is a sum s for
sum because everybody in those days knew
Latin and Greek and this one is also an
F but gradually it was such an important
s that they made it bigger and then they
stretched it out and made it a little
thinner because it didn't fit into one
type setting space and so just for
typesetting reason it got stretched and
got a little bit skinny anyway so it's
really an S and and in fact in French
they call it sum even though they we
call it integral so it's it's it's a sum
all right so it's consistent with sums
in this way and similarly similarly we
can factor constants out of sums so if
you have a integral like this the
constant factors out
but definitely don't try to get a
function out of this that that won't
happen okay in other words C has to be a
constant doesn't depend on X all right
the third property well what do I want
to call the third property here I have a
sort of a preliminary property yes here
which is the following and I'll draw a
picture of it suppose you have three
points along the line so then I'm going
to draw a picture of that and I'm going
to use the interpretation above the
curve even though that's not the whole
thing so here's a here's B and here's C
and you can see that the area of this
piece of the first two pieces here is
when added together gives you the area
of the whole and that's the rule that
I'd like to tell you so if you integrate
from A to B and you add to that the
integral from B to C you'll get the
integral from A to C this is going to be
just a little preliminary because the
rule is a little better than this but I
will explain that in a in a minute the
fourth rule is a very simple one which
is that the integral from a to a of f of
X DX is equal to zero that you can see
very obviously because there's no area
no horizontal movement there the
rectangle is infinitely thin and there's
nothing there so this is the case you
can also interpret it as f of a minus F
of a so that's also consistent with our
interpretation in terms of the
fundamental theorem of calculus and it's
perfectly reasonable that this is the
case
now the fifth property is is is a
definition it's not really a property
but it's very important the integral
from A to B of f of X DX is equal to
minus the integral from B to a of f of X
DX now really the right-hand side here
is an undefined quantity so far we never
said that you could ever do this where
the where the where the where the a is
less than the B right because this is
working backwards here all right but we
just have a convention that that's the
definition whenever we write down this
number it's the same as minus what that
number is and the reason for all of
these is again that we want them to be
consistent with the fundamental theorem
of calculus which is the thing that
makes all this work so if you if you
notice the the left-hand side here is f
of B minus F of a capital F the
antiderivative of little F on the other
hand the other side is minus and if we
just ignore that we say these are
letters if we were machine we didn't
know which one was bigger than which we
just plugged them in we would get here F
of a minus F of B over here and to make
these two things equal what we want us
to put that minus sign and now it's
consistent so again these rules are set
up so that so that everything is
consistent and now I want to improve on
Rule 3 here and point out to you so let
me just go back to rule 3 for a second
that now that we can evaluate integrals
regardless of the order we don't have to
have a less than B be less than C in
order to make sense out of this we
actually have the possibility of
considering integrals where the where
the A's and the B's are in the Caesar in
any order you want and in fact with this
definition with this definition 5/3
works no matter what the numbers are so
this is much more convenient we don't
this is not necessary not necessary
it just works using convention five okay
with five all right again before I go on
let me emphasize it's we really want to
respect the sign of this velocity we
really want the net change in the
position and we don't want this absolute
value here because otherwise all of our
formulas are going to mess up we won't
always be able to check sometimes you
know you have letters rather than rather
than actual numbers here and you won't
know whether a is bigger than B so
you'll want to know that these formulas
work and are consistent in in all
situations okay I'm going to trade these
again in order to preserve the ordering
one through five and now I have a sixth
property that I want to talk about this
one is called estimation and it says the
following if f of X is less than or
equal to G of X then the integral from A
to B of f of X DX is less than or equal
to the integral from A to B of G of X X
now this one says that if I'm going more
slowly than you then you go farther than
I do okay that's all it's saying for
this one you'd better have a is less
than B you need it because we flip the
signs when we flip the order of a and B
so this one it's essential that the
lower limit be smaller than the upper
limit but let me just emphasize because
we're dealing with the generalities of
this actually if one of these is
negative and the other one is negative
then it also works okay this one ends up
being this is this if F is more negative
than G then this added up thing is more
negative than that one okay again under
the assumption that a is less than B all
right so it's it's it's as I wrote it
it's it's in it's in full generality all
right I let let's illustrate this one
and then we have one more property to
learn after that so let me give you an
example of estimation the example is the
same as one that I already gave you but
this time because we have the tool of
integration we can just follow our noses
and it works I'll start with the
inequality so I'm trying to illustrate
estimation so I want to start with an
equality which is what the hypothesis is
here and I'm going to integrate the
inequality to get this conclusion and
see what what conclusion it is the
inequality that I want to take is that e
to the X is greater than or equal to 1
for X greater than or equal to 0 that's
going to be our start starting place
and now I'm going to integrate it that
is I'm going to use estimation to see
what that gives well I'm going to
integrate say from zero to B I can't
integrate below zero because it's only
true above zero this is e to the X DX
greater than or equal to the integral
from zero to B of 1 DX alright let's
work out what each of these is the first
one e to the X DX is the antiderivative
is e to the X evaluated at 0 and B so
that's e to the B minus e to the 0 which
is e to the B minus 1 the other one
you're supposed to be able to get by the
by the rectangle law this is one
rectangle of base B and height 1 so the
answer is B or you can do it by
anti-derivatives but it's B that means
that our inequality says if I just
combine these two things together that e
to the B minus 1 is greater than or
equal to B and that's the same thing as
e to the B is greater than or equal to 1
plus B again this only works for B
greater than or equal to 0 notice that
if B were negative this would be a
well-defined quantity but this
estimation would be false all right we
need that the B be bigger than 0 in
order for this to make sense so this is
this was used and that's a good thing
because this inequality is is suspect
actually it turns out to be true when B
is negative but it seemed that whedon
certainly didn't prove it all right I'm
going to just repeat this process so
let's repeat it
starting from the inequality the
conclusion which is sitting right here
but I'll write it in the form e to the X
greater than or equal to 1 plus X for X
greater than or equal to zero and now if
I integrate this one I get the integral
from zero to be e to the X DX is greater
than or equal to the integral from 0 to
be 1 plus X DX and I remind you that
we've already calculated this one this
is e to the B minus 1
and the other one is not hard to
calculate the antiderivative is X plus x
squared over 2 we're evaluating at that
at 0 and B so that comes out to be that
comes out to be B plus B squared over 2
and so our conclusion is our conclusion
is that the left side which is e to the
B minus 1 is greater than or equal to B
plus B squared over 2 and this is for B
greater than or equal to 0 and that's
the same thing as e to the B greater
than or equal to 1 plus B plus B squared
over 2 this one actually is is false for
B negative so that's something that you
have to be careful with the B positives
here all right so you can keep on going
with this and you didn't have to think
and you'll produce a very interesting
polynomial which is a good approximation
to e to the B all right so that's that's
it for the basic properties now there's
one tricky property that I need to tell
you about it's not that tricky but it's
a little tricky
and this is this is change of variables
change of variables in integration we've
actually already done we called that the
last time we talked about it we call it
substitution and the idea here if you
may remember was that if you're faced
with an integral like this you can
change it to if you put in U is equal to
u of X and you have a D U which is equal
to u prime of X D u DF sorry then you
can change the integral as follows this
is the same as G of U of X u prime of X
DX this was the general procedure for
substitution what's new today is that
we're going to put in the limits if you
have a limit here u 1 and a limit here
you two you want to know what the
relationship is between the limits here
and the limits when you change variables
to the new variables and it's the
simplest possible thing namely the two
limits over here are in the same
relationship as U of X is 2 to this
symbol u here in other words u 1 is
equal to u of X 1 and u 2 is equal to U
of X 2 that's what works
now there's only one danger here there's
one one subtlety which is we this only
works if only works if you crime does
not change sign
I've been worrying a little bit about
going backwards and forwards and I
allowed myself to reverse and do all
kinds of stuff right with these
integrals so we were sort of free to do
it well this is one case where you want
to avoid it okay just don't do it
it is possible actually make sense out
of it but it's also possible to get
yourself infinitely confused
so just make sure that now it's okay if
you prime is always negative you're
always going one way so okay if you
prime is always positive you're always
going the other way but if you mix them
up you'll get yourself mixed up alright
let me give you an example the example
will be maybe close to what we did last
time it did did when we first did
substitution on e let's see so the the
integral from one to two this time I'll
put in definite limits of x squared plus
sorry maybe I call this X cubed x cubed
plus two let's say I don't know to the
fifth power x squared DX all right so
this is an example of an integral that
we would have tried to handle by
substitution before and the substitution
we would have used is u equals x cubed
plus two and that's exactly what we're
going to do here but we're just going to
also take into account the limits
the first step as in any substitution or
change of variables is is this alright
and so we can fill in the things that we
would have done previously which is that
this is the integral and this is U to
the fifth power and then because this is
3x squared we see that this is a 3 sorry
let's write it the other way
one-third D U is equal to x squared DX
so that's what I'm going to plug in for
this factor here so here's one third to
you which replaces that but now there's
the extra feature the extra feature is
the limits so here really in disguise
because and now this is incredibly
important this is one of the reasons why
we use this notation DX and D U we want
to remind ourselves which variable is
involved in the integration and
especially if you're the one naming the
variables you may get mixed up in this
respect so you must know which variable
is varying between 1 and 2 and the
answer is its X is the one that's vary
between 1 & 2 so in disguise even though
I didn't write it it was contained in
this little symbol here this reminded us
which variable you'll find this
amazingly important when you get to
multivariable calculus when there are
many variables floating around so this
is incredibly important distinction to
make so now over here we have a limit
but it's of course it's supposed to be
with respect to you now so we need to
calculate what those corresponding
limits are and indeed it's just I plug
in here u1 is going to be equal to what
I plug in for x equals 1 that's going to
be 1 cubed plus 2 which is 3 and then u2
is 2 cubed plus 2 which is equal to 10
right 8 plus 2 is 10 so this is the
integral from 3 to 10 of U to the 5th
times 1/3 D you
and now I can finish the problem this is
1:18 you to the sixth power from three
to ten and this is where the most common
mistake is occurs in substitutions of
this type which is that if you ignore
this and you plug in these one and two
here you think oh I should just be
putting it at one and two but actually
it should be the you value that we're
interested in and the lower limit is U
equals three and u equals that ten is
the upper limit all right so those are
suppressed here that those are the ones
that that we want and so here we go it's
118th times some ridiculous number which
I won't calculate 10 to the sixth minus
three to the sixth yes question
so if you if you want to do things with
where you're where you're where you're
worrying about the sign change the right
strategy is what you suggested works and
in fact I'm going to do an example right
now on this subject but the right
strategy is to break it up into pieces
where you prime has one sign or the
other okay let me show you an example
okay but where things go wrong and I'll
I'll tell you how to handle it roughly
so here's our warning suppose you're
integrating 4 minus minus 1 to 1 x
squared DX here's an example and you had
the temptation you had the temptation to
plug in U is equal to x squared now of
course we know how to integrate this but
but let's just pretend we want we were
stubborn and wanted to use substitution
then we have D U is equal to 2 X DX all
right and now if I try to make the
correspondence notice that the limits
are u 1 is what it is is a negative 1
squared that's the bottom limit and u 2
is the upper limit that's 1 squared
that's also equal to 1 both limits are 1
so this is going from 1 to 1 and no
matter what it is we know it's going to
be 0 but we know this is not 0 this is
the integral of a positive quantity and
it's the area under a curve that it's
going to be a positive area so this is a
positive quantity you can't be 0 if you
actually plug it in it looks equally
strange it you put in here this you
and then so that would be for the U
squared and then to plug in for DX you
would write DX is equal to 1 over 2 X D
U and then you might write that as as
this alright and so what we should put
in here is this quantity here which is a
perfectly okay integral and it has a
value I mean it's it's what it is it's
zero so of course this is not true and
the reason is that u was equal to x
squared and u prime of X was equal to 2x
which was positive for X positive and
negative for X negative and this was the
sign change which which causes us
trouble if we break it up into its two
halves then you'll it'll be okay and
you'll be able to use this now there was
a mistake and this was essentially what
what you were saying that is that
there's it's possible to see this
happening as you're doing it if you're
very careful there's a mistake in this
process and the mistake is in the
transition this is this is a mistake
here maybe I haven't used any read yet
today so I get to use some red here oh
boy all right
this is this is not true here this step
here so why isn't it true it's not true
for the the standard reason which is
that really X is equal to plus or minus
square root of u and if you stick to one
side or the other you'll have a coherent
formula for it one of them will be the
plus and one of them will be the minus
and it will work out when you separate
it into its pieces so you could do that
but this is a can of worms so I avoid
this and just do it in a place where the
where the where the inverse is
well-defined and where the function
either moves steadily up or steadily
down